one of the largest evacuations in
Australian history is underway today as
massive bush fires burn out of control
their Navy ships helped evacuate
hundreds of people from beaches along
the country's southeastern coast and
this is the town of mallacoota which has
been cut off for days by the devastating
fires more than 200 fires in all burning
and Australia's two most heavily
populated states that's New South Wales
and Victoria extreme heat and strong
winds are in the forecast for tomorrow
and that could literally fan the flames
which have already destroyed hundreds of
homes and killed at least 19 people CBS
news meteorologist and climate
specialist Jeff bird Ellie is here
Jeff good morning morning so what's the
latest on the weather pattern we're
seeing in Australia so you know we are
seeing unprecedented conditions and
again today and tomorrow it's going to
be extremely hot let's set it up by
talking about what's been happening over
the past couple of years we are in a
three-year drought in Australia and on
top of that 2019 the hottest and driest
year on record and just a couple of
weeks ago you may remember this Tony
they hit a hundred and seven degrees for
the average temperature of the whole
country breaking their own record by
three degrees Fahrenheit as a
meteorologist that is remarkable almost
seems like it's not possible but it
happened so what causes it right so what
we have going on right now is something
called an Indian Ocean dipole pattern
that's a typical pattern it's kind of
like El Nino and La Nina so it goes back
and forth over the course of years and
this year we've had an extreme Indian
Ocean dipole in fact a record Indian
Ocean dipole what that's doing is it's
causing warm water in the western part
of the Indian Ocean and cool water in
the eastern part of the Indian Ocean
so we end up with rising air over the
western part of the ocean right near
Africa that causes rain but sinking air
dry air in the eastern part of the
Indian Ocean that causes Indonesia and
Australia to dry out so we have an
extreme pattern of this that's happening
right now on top of what's happening
with climate change so the pattern is
naturally occurring right climate change
could make it more intense right so
there first of all there's a study out
that climate change is baking this
natural pattern worse and more extreme
but in addition to that we're seeing
gradual trends take place over the past
century or so and a couple of those are
this so first of all the number of
extreme heat days take a look at this
in 1910 1920 almost zero extreme heat
days and now we're up to an average of
around 15 that really dries out the soil
you can imagine the amount of heat in
addition the gradual increase in
temperature both of the ocean and also
of the atmosphere has gone up in fact
the air has gone up around three degrees
Fahrenheit over a hundred years again
that gradually dries out the brush
lastly fire danger in the southeast
corner especially of Australia look at
how much it's gone up over the past four
decades or so so this is a situation
where climate change is kind of a
background when you have a natural
pattern that's causing extreme fire
danger climate change spikes it it
enhances it it turns extreme fire danger
into catastrophic fire danger so would
your expectation be let's talk Therese
here would you expect to see more fires
like this in Australia and switching to
the US context are we gonna see a
similar pattern there's no doubt about
it
in Australia they're in the subtropics
we call it the rich get richer the poor
get poorer what we mean by that is
places that get a lot of rain will get
more rain places that are dry luck or
Australia will continue to get drier and
drier it will get worse there in the
United States and places like California
not every year is a bad fire year but
when it's dry for a couple years in a
row it will progressively get worse and
this will become kind of a new norm but
only worse one more thing I want to add
is people are already having trouble
getting insurance and mortgages in fire
prone areas of California that's gonna
exacerbate the situation not only for
fires but also for folks that are flood
prone and folks that live near sea level
once you can't get a mortgage or
insurance on your home you no longer can
sell your home you don't like hearing
the word fire and normal in the same
sense yeah Jeff thank you very much
you